and the red light come on and then it
should be yet they go
no I'm just gonna say good evening
toilet I'm sorry I know it's all good
evening everyone
just in case anyone needs toilets they
are through those doors and to the left
we'll be starting in another 10 minutes
well good evening everyone will make a
start
Kennedy say welcome to Stratford
District Council in the Elizabeth house
my name is Tony Jefferson I'm leader of
Stratford District Council can I also
say that we're going to finish just
before 8 o'clock
when were approached to host this event
we're only too pleased to do it
EU citizens are our residence and we're
committed to helping all our residents
in whatever way we can
so just want you to be very very clear
on that and we are committed to helping
one of the things we hope to get out of
this evening is some guidance on the
kind of help you may need and I should
say that this event will be recorded it
will be available on our on YouTube on
our website tomorrow and whatever
happens as we move forwards and whatever
is going to happen
and we only wish we knew what it was
do not be afraid to contact us if we
can't answer a question we'll find out
the answer and get back to you so with
that thank you all for coming the local
coordinator for Warwickshire for the 3
million and the 3 million is a
not-for-profit organization which
campaigns to preserve the rights of EU
Nationals post proxied and we want to
thank staff for this frequency for being
proactive and for taking the lead in
Warwickshire in the organization of such
an important event and also the Law
Center's Network and the European
Commission representation in the UK
which made possible the event and Eileen
bile our lawyer will give a presentation
and then we
time for questions from the public but
just before we start we would like to
alight that the new EU settlement scheme
negotiated by the UK government and the
EU consists of a reduction of our rights
over current rights in particular with
regards to family reunion and absence
from the UK and therefore for us remains
unsatisfactory and it also raises a
series of concerns our main concerns are
the future change of two rights without
proper parliamentary scrutiny as settled
status is at the moment secondary
legislation the loss of rights in case
of No Deal which I did my talk about
later on almost these mistakes in
granting settled status or no granting
set of status and access to our own data
when we mount an appeal in case of
refusal of the ROM status being granted
and because of the extension in the Data
Protection Act 2018 which the three
million is currently challenging in
court and also the absence of a material
certificate which could raise concerns
when we apply for jobs for mortgages for
landlords and so on so our lives have
been put on out for nine hundred days
and the government not the paper on
citizens rights does not deliver
certainty and move further limit arise
so what we are asking is that citizens
rights need to be taken off the table
immediately whatever there is a deal not
deal or a people's vote ring-fencing a
rights is the only answer
and if the government terming finds the
rights of Swiss Nationals for example he
should also be able with goodwill to
ring-fence the rights of the citizens of
other European nationalities and on the
point that we need to ally not to start
thank you for coming as Manuela said I
been sent here by the law centers
Network these sessions around the
country are funded by the European
Commission but the law centers Network
an independent charitable body is
coordinating quite a lot of them and
we're independent of course nothing to
do with the Home Office
so we're independent one thing the
European Commission was very anxious
that I remind people of is that there
are European elections coming up in May
23 to 26 May and many of you will have
the right to vote in the European
elections and so please don't forget to
get in touch with your consulates about
the arrangements for you to vote in your
elections the European elections in May
we're going to go through a pack of
slides explaining the new settled status
scheme which is the new scheme designed
by the Home Office in agreement with
other European Union countries to
protect the rights of EU citizens
resident in the UK and similarly UK
citizens resident in other EU countries
there's about 50 odd slides so some of
them I'll go through in summary form but
the usefulness of the slides is that you
can have a copy an email abour copy so
that if you want to go through them
again after the session that can be
quite useful the information I'm going
to be delivering this evening is based
on there being some sort of a deal that
is there are many things about brexit
the European leaving the UK leaving the
European Union
but one of the areas that is relatively
secure relates to the rights of EU
citizens resident in the UK and that's
because that little bit of the deal has
largely been agreed between the UK and
the EU so what I'm talking about tonight
is more likely than not to happen
because it's largely agreed between the
EU and the UK at the end I'll also talk
about the event of a no deal that is if
the end of March comes and we haven't
actually finally agreed a deal with the
EU or an extension to give us more time
if that happens most much of what I am
talking about will still be the same the
plan for EU migrant workers will still
be the same there will be some
differences and at the end I'll outline
the differences separately to try and
avoid getting more mixed up so most of
this evening to talk is going to be
about the deal for EU migrants resident
in the UK as it's been agreed between
the Home Office which is the UK
government body responsible for
immigration and other EU states and
although as manuela said many people can
be very unhappy that we have to be here
tonight talking about this but at the
same time in the deal that's agreed
there are a number of positives and the
Home Office has stressed repeatedly that
is designed to protect the rights of EU
were of EU residents and also EU family
members who may not be au citizens so
there are a number of positives
right can everybody see a screen feel
free to move there are a few spare seats
about if you can't see a screen I've
more or less said this about the role of
the European Commission and the Law
Center's network in providing these
information sessions can I also say to
that if I say something and you don't
understand what I'm saying don't worry
about putting your hand up to ask me at
the time for clarification but there
will be time at the end for questions
and answers and I've made clear that I'm
not rushing off so if you want to come
and see me at the end of the session if
you've got any worries that's fine too
I'll be hanging around ok ok so we're
going to talk about the right the
current right to reside currently of
course you're all benefiting from EU law
in your right to reside here that's
going to change at the end of March
likely at the end of March and become an
e and new EU settlement scheme and at
the end questions and answers just a
reminder that although I might be
talking about EU Nationals what I'm
saying the agreed plan applies not just
to the other 27 EU states but also also
the additional European free trade
agreement stays they making up the EE
a Iceland Liechtenstein Norway and also
Switzerland so although their status is
slightly different to the EU countries
it's the same plan for people who are
resident from those countries if there's
anybody here from
those countries that's just a reminder
that the current right to reside doesn't
actually require very much you may
remember that when you came here all you
did when you arrived was show your EU
passport and that's it that's all you
have to do prove you were a citizen of
an EU nation and you could come in you
could do what you wanted you could
work-study claim benefits health care
stay as long as you like and over a
period of time you could have an
extended right of residence permanent
residence after five years if you would
chose to but it was purely optional no
compulsion you didn't have to do
anything other than waive your passport
around and even acquire but to go on to
acquire British citizenship by
naturalization that of course is
changing because you will now have to do
something that is whereas as an EU
national you didn't have to do anything
no matter how many years you've been
here it was optional you could apply for
some sort of residence permit or
permanent residence the whole point of
the transition period that we're talking
about today is we're changing from EU
law which is benign to UK law which is
restrictive it's designed to be
restrictive and it's designed to require
you to do things make applications so
one thing you must take away from
tonight despite all the speculation and
rumors is that you do have to prepare
you do have to do something you do have
to prepare to apply for settled status
under the new scheme because that's the
way UK immigration rules work
separately and I'm sorry that people at
the back might not be able to see it
very well I've put up a separate
timeline the timeline is also explained
in the slides but just so that we can
keep this up permanently as the slides
roll I've put up a timeline and of
course the timeline is that
brexit days the end of March then
there's a long transition period the
transition period goes on until the end
of December 31 December 2020 and even
after that while you're preparing your
application provided your resident by
the qualifying day December 2020 you can
still make your application within a
further six months that's the timeline
that's the timeline that we're going to
be referring to repeatedly and one of
the difference is is that the qualifying
by the 29th of March 2019 is the
deadline in the event of no deal but
you'll still have a transition view you
don't look
horrified you still have a transition
period in which to prepare your
application I'll come to that don't
worry yes
well that's a very good question and
you're right if somebody's already got a
permanent residence blue card which is a
secure status
the fact is under the new scheme they
still
and well they won't even be asked for it
yeah sorry back it's just it's just part
of the scheme yeah the we're going to be
talking about the draft withdrawal
agreement which means it hasn't been
finally ratified but it has been agreed
and that's the plan for the new state of
new civil status affecting
throughout the transition period which
is from 29 March until the end of
December 2020
EU law still applies so in the diagram
I've put up the blue line means EU law
still applies freedom of movement you
can come and go you don't have to worry
about your status at the end of March
you can carry on coming and going and so
can your family members once the
transition period ends which is 31
December 2020 you law will finish in the
UK and after that UK immigration rules
will apply even though existing EU
residents might still be preparing their
applications for settled status and my
advice would be to try and get your
applications to register with the home
workers before the end of the transition
period 31 December 22 2000 than waiting
in to the extra tolerated six-month
period
the scheme to read to apply to register
has been open for test cases in recent
months so a number of people have been
able to apply if they meet certain
conditions in recent months it will be
open for all by the end of March well
when I say there have been tests it's
true that one of the test phases has
been opened on the 21st of January for
EU citizens but was a bit of a
qualification only for those with
current valid passports so it was still
limiting in effect but the purpose of
the tests is to make sure that it works
and they can keep moderating
but you're right
currently EU citizens can present either
a passport or an ID card just EU
citizens and the intention here is that
it will continue that Europeans can
present either an ID card or a passport
for a period of time however the Home
Office is committed to digitalization
and during the test phases you can only
apply if you've got a current valid
passport the reason being that
have a little black rectangle on the
front and on the photo page which means
it can be read by a machine which ID
cards often don't have not all
for the time being geez yes
well but at least thought they said for
five years but don't necessarily trust
what the Home Office stays into the
distant future okay right
well possibly yes except that certain
things have been agreed
I'm not saying on 100% sure that that is
set in concrete that that cannot change
nobody can say that Prime Minister can't
say that so but it's it's likely that
the main components of what we're
describing tonight will obtain will
endure they will go through but once we
move beyond
No
the reason I put this additional chart
up is to emphasize there's a transition
period correct of course there may be an
extension which extends it but the
transition period as agreed is till the
end of 2020 so that's quite a long
transition period okay and now I'm quite
anxious to be able to go through the
main components of the scheme and there
will be a lot of time for questions at
the end
and
please bear in mind that when we finish
being part of the EU after the end of
the transition period we then go into UK
immigration rules so any EU nationals
arriving after then will have to qualify
under normal UK immigration rules which
mean that normally people wanting to
come here to work have to have a certain
level of skills certain level of salary
to qualify so it may be much more
difficult for people to come and work
after the end of the transition period
this diagram just explains that
currently there are dual systems people
subject non EU citizens were subject to
immigration control under UK immigration
law up until the end of March and during
the transition period EA regulations a
much kinder EA law applies to EU
citizens and those who wished to apply
for citizenship after a certain period
of time residents in the UK apply under
British nationality law and underpinning
all of those we still have international
human rights treaty obligations UK
didn't opt out of international human
rights law when they opted out
and we've said that the non-iea States
eat the EI states have not got at the EU
are also protected right under the
scheme who is protected well obviously
it's EU citizens and their family
members who by 31 December 2020 have
been residing in the UK sorry I've been
residing in the UK
I'm pleased the main date that you have
to take away tonight is the end of the
transition period 31st of December 2020
you have to qualify by that date as I
have said free movement EU law continues
through this period meaning people can
come and go so obviously those present
tonight are resident in the UK because
you're here but if you wanted to go back
home you could come and go if you had a
family member or a friend who wanted to
come and live in the UK so long as they
get here by the 31st of December 2020
they qualify as UK residents who can
apply under the settled status scheme so
that's the most important date to take
away 31 December 2020 tonight and of
course some people may have gone home
for Christmas in December 2020 just
because they are out if they've already
been resident in the UK they don't lose
their residence by going home for
Christmas person they could still come
back and make the application on the
basis that their residents
but of course my advice is to apply
before the end of the transition period
rather than leave it till the last
minute in the additional six months but
you have that option
does anybody know what continuous
residence means
yes that's true that that's true and
continuous residents means you have to
be in the UK at least six months in any
12-month period so if you went home for
Christmas and didn't come back for six
months you would break your continuous
residence
she's home whenever yeah I know yes of
course yeah
well
for a period of time you'll still have
an EU passport and in many cases in EU
residence permit and at the border there
going to be no no that's right no it's
an online application and the records
will also be online and can be accessed
online so immigration officers yes yeah
yes I wonder if we can come to this once
we go because we're jumping ahead quite
a lot here thank you
family members I said that the
protection applies not just to people
who are EU citizens but their family
members and some of the family members
may not themselves be EU citizens so for
example a French citizen may have
married a Brazilian or a German may have
married an Algerian so the family member
is not himself herself an EU citizen and
therefore couldn't necessarily benefit
from EU law however EU law works as an
umbrella
it protects family members regardless of
citizenship it protects specific family
members spouses husbands wives civil
partners also partners who have been
living together for a long time as if
they were man and wife at least two
years
so those relationships are also
protected then in the descending line
children of either partner are protected
grandchildren and usefully under EU law
a child qualifies protection up to the
age of 21 whereas in the UK of course
you cease being a minor a child at the
age of 18 and in fact even a child who's
over 21 if they're still dependent on
the parents can qualify for that
protection
parents and grandparents if their
dependents can also gather the same
protection and it's assumed that parents
and grandparents are dependent so there
isn't really a dependency test
there are some exceptions to the
requirement to be resident here by the
end of the transition period 31 December
2020 if children are born in the future
to parents resident here they can still
obviously join them here they can still
qualify and that includes future
children adopted by the EU citizen or
their partner
are there any Irish citizens here
tonight aarush citizens have a special
relationship with the UK because Ireland
is part of the common travel area with
free movement which preceded EU
membership Irish citizens do not lead do
not need permission to be here so they
can choose to apply for settled status
and certainly if their family members
aren't EU nationals it would be
beneficial for their family members to
apply for settled status but Irish
citizens don't need to because they
don't need permission to live in the UK
or work here anyway
health care pensions and benefits
education other rights no change there's
going to be no change I'm not saying
there won't be any change in the future
because much of that is based on
reciprocity so whatever is agreed
between the different EU countries in
terms of health care or pension rights
social security coordination measures
and aggregation there is a commitment to
maintaining coordinated social security
rights and maintaining coordinated
reciprocal health care rights but it may
differ between different countries in
the future but at the moment it's the
same same as it has been and now I'm
going to talk about the EU settlement
scheme which is the new scheme under
which EU citizens and their family
members have to register
it will involve two sorts of status I'm
just going to remind people that there
are three expressions that come up a lot
and they all meet the same although I'm
aware that sometimes people get confused
permanent residents indefinite leave and
settled status they all mean the same
thing they all mean that there is no
time limit on your permission to live in
the UK and there are no conditions or
restrictions
so in effect those expressions mean the
most secure status you can have short of
British citizenship the word leave which
confuses a lot of people in the
immigration context it means permission
so it's quite an old English word it
comes up in Shakespearean texts it also
comes up a lot in home office texts and
it means permission permission to be
here indefinite leave which you will see
a lot in Home Office documents means no
time limit no restrictions so it means
the same as settled status but the Home
Office has chosen to call the new scheme
settled status but in the same documents
they will use indefinitely it's the same
thing
the best status is settled status you
higher settle status by being an EU
citizen or family member
resident in the UK for five years by
June 2021 that's including the tolerated
period to get your application sorted
beyond the end of the transition period
if you haven't if you can't tell the
Home Office thing you've been here for
five years continuously in the UK as a
resident if you've been here for less
than five years what you will get is
called pre settled status meaning you
are clocking off five years so for
example if you arrived in 2016 so you've
now got three years you make your
application to the Home Office under the
new scheme the Home Office says well you
haven't got five years so we can't give
you settled status you've got three
years they will then give you a five
year pre settled status you don't have
to spend the full five years because if
you add up your existing three years and
another two years you will then have
your five years so you could apply for a
settled status once you've got the five
years partway through your preset status
and once you've done that you don't have
to apply for anything else because
settled status means no time you make no
restrictions
you have to notify them but that doesn't
mean to say that you're making a fresh
application you have to notify them
that's true because there's no time
limit online again
yeah yeah
well
it's difficult for me to tell you
Shirley what's gonna happen over the
years sorry no but the simple fact is
settled status means indefinitely it
means there is no time with me
it doesn't finish five years time but
that is true the Home Office can say but
we need updates so if you get a new
passport you're supposed to tell us
otherwise at the border they won't know
next time you come in and I agree that
that's a big burden but what it doesn't
mean is that yours it settles data's
ends it just means the Home Office wants
updating in the same way that for
residents cards now if you move or every
10 years they want a new photograph
because your photograph will look
different in 10 years time so but it
doesn't mean to say that you're settle
status ends that's the important thing
No
it's true there is speculative
information going around but currently
EU nationals can travel either using an
identity card or a passport and that
will stay the same and I'm sure by the
time they start saying well we're
phasing out use of identity cards the
trend is that all everything is going to
be online in the future everything is
going to be online with the idea that
being that is instant
well let's not speculate beyond what
we're describing tonight the application
system is despite what we're just saying
the home of his aim is that it be
streamlined and user-friendly drawn
existing government data and work with
applicants to to help to avoid errors
and admissions I understand that during
the test phases so far so before the end
of March that Home Office has been
running test phases amongst higher
education social services health care
and more recently EU nationals with a
current valid passport and they've dealt
with about 10,000 applications and I
have been told by the head of legal at
the home office that they've only
refused a handful so that's that's good
um
right there are three key requirements
of the settle status process inevitably
you have to prove your identity and
nationality they that's the passport
currently you can present a current
valid passport or a current valid ID
card but if your ID card isn't digitally
readable you have to send it to the home
office and that means that it might take
a bit longer although they are supposed
to just look at it and send it straight
back even before they've decided so it's
still supposed to be dealt with within
two weeks I understand most of them are
being dealt with within two weeks which
is phenomenal given the normal home
office timescales secondly you have to
prove your length of residence in the UK
does anybody know how they're doing
better
yes yes that that's right when you apply
one of the pieces of information you
have to give is your National Insurance
number the National Insurance number
serves two purposes one is it links you
with your tax record your work record
the other is that it links you with any
benefits claims what am i doing
it links you with your benefits claims
so in fact most people just by virtue of
what's recorded against their National
Insurance number the evidence of
continuous residence is there the home
office isn't going to want great bundle
of papers they say they only roughly
want one document for six months so even
if for some reason you you hadn't been
in the UK working paying tax or claiming
benefits such as child benefit so there
was no National Insurance Number record
of you and therefore you have to find
alternative evidence you only have to
provide selected documents over the
period you've been here covering at
least every six month period can you
think of any examples of alternative
documents that you might thanks Tina
it's very good yeah council tax free yep
P sixty that's right yet although if
you've got a P 60 that will have your
National Insurance number on it so you
won't need to provide it they can see it
um brain just yep anything from your
landlord rent schools doctors health
care so there's lots of official stuff
yes
well
yes that's true yes
yeah
documented no but the examples you give
and presumably they have children if you
know about them because of the school
then they'll be getting child benefit
the child benefits in the mother's name
and she will have a National Insurance
number it's only for the child benefit
child tax credit also names both parents
and they both have National Insurance
numbers so um it can be
no that's fine
no no I was about to go on to say that
one of the positives about the new
scheme is that if you look at the second
bullet point you only have to prove
residents in the UK so anybody here who
chose to apply previously to the Home
Office for permanent residents they will
very well remember that they had to send
evidence of two things one residence to
work economic activity could be in other
studies or self-sufficiency but usually
it's work economic activity only
residents the home office is only
interested in residents so for a lot of
people with a very patchy work history
they don't need to worry about it
as long as the national insurance
through is helpfully clocking up some
bits of work bits of benefits when
they're not working purely as evidence
of residents then provided that evidence
of continuous residence for the claimed
period is there they will still qualify
under the settled status scheme that's a
very big benefit and that's new we don't
need evidence of work you just need
evidence of residence that's all and
although checking the National Insurance
number is designed to make it easier
because the home office computer talked
to the tax computer
computer against the National Insurance
number so the Home Office can read that
information without you sending it to
them they can read it automatically but
if for example you arrived here a year
ago you were involved in a horrible road
traffic accident you spent the past year
in hospital so you haven't worked you
haven't claimed benefits therefore your
National Insurance record will not prove
your residents for the past year
then Hospital letter will do the same
job so you just have to be aware as part
of your preparation but firstly you have
to make sure you've got up-to-date
evidence of identity and nationality
secondly think about the period that
you're telling the Home Office you've
lived here for one year two years three
years five years ten years will
something show up on your national
insurance record for all of those years
if yes find the home office computer
will read it your residence risk will be
confirmed if not if there are gaps think
about alternatives to submit to the home
office
there is a third of computer that the
home office computer talks to that's the
police national computer for every home
office application there are questions
about criminality
even if you've got minor offending you
got into a fight somewhere it was in
your the country you came from or it was
a long time ago and therefore you can't
even remember very well you've still got
to declare it and it's very important to
bear this in mind the home office is
very keen on getting this information so
if you got into a fight or you kicked
the chicken in Poland two years ago and
got charged with criminal damage then
even if you can't remember exactly what
you were charged with exactly when it
was when the Home Office asks the
question have you been involved have you
had any convictions you have to mention
it you don't have to say exactly what
exactly when but if you mention it it
shows you are not hiding it mine are
offending a long time ago the home
office doesn't care they won't refuse
the application but if you don't mention
it and they find it they do care they
came more about that than the offense
itself because they call that deception
and that's very serious as far as the
home office is concerned so any minor
offending of any sort in the UK or in
other countries is best be on the safe
side and mention it even if it's only to
the best of your memory we don't have to
send detailed document
just be up front the Home Office checks
not just the police national computer in
the UK they check European countries as
well
and I've just explained that there are a
number of positives involved in the
scheme and you don't have to show
evidence that you've been working you've
just got to show evidence of residence
so that's a positive and there were some
people students people who are
self-sufficient not working you also in
the past have had to show they had
comprehensive sickness insurance if they
were applying for permanent residents
that's gone as well that requirement as
from the Home Office is just simplified
they're only interested in evidence of
residence
it's an online form
and if anybody is being into the Home
Office website since the 21st of January
which is the first phase for EU citizens
came online for EU citizens who had the
current valid passport
they will have seen that open up at 9:00
a.m. on the 21st of January and the will
then have followed some information
about how to apply there's two stages
the two stages are firstly you have to
download an application via the home
office website or Google Play
and I've already shown produced my
passport to illustrate the little logo a
rectangle with a circle in the middle
which means near-field communication and
which is also used on in credit cards
for contact was pay and
once you've downloaded the application
on your device the first thing is you've
got to have the right sort of device how
many here have got an Apple iPhone right
so you can't do it
um well it has it has to be a phone but
it has to be a phone with an Android
device uh we you can do yes but you've
got to have the near-field communication
and not all that tops have it you've got
to have Android near-field communication
not an older and some of the older
Android devices don't have it either so
so if you've got the right sort of
laptop you might be able to do it but
[Music]
yep
thank you yes but for anybody who
couldn't hear that the gentleman who
successfully done it is explaining that
yes you have to have an Android device
which you put on and you don't download
the Home Office application which then
reads your passport so you put your
phone on your passport both on the front
and back where the little logo is and on
the data page where the logo is and the
phone prompts you it will tell you if
it's engaged or not turn the volume up
because it beeps you need to hear it
beep also have a pen and paper to hand
in case you are asked any questions you
have to write them down quick and I
understand the near-field communication
is often at the top of the phone so if
you have to move it around use the top
of the film once
yeah yeah
No No
now it's it is it isn't it doesn't save
no no it doesn't save doesn't say in the
ether
that's right and so firstly you have to
do I'll just finish yep yep firstly you
have to download the application and
then it reads your passport but then
there's a second thing on the same
application you have to take your photo
so part of the same application photo
don't have the kids in the background
giggling and try and have a normal plain
background that of the flesh then the
Home Office then will give they will
they give you a reference number against
that so they then capture that
information and that reference number
enables you to carry on communicating
against your reference number the second
part of the stage after you've gone
through the application uploading your
passport information your face your
photograph there's a short online form
you can't do the online form till you've
done the first bit the online form
either I'm told to take six or seven
minutes to fill out name address date of
birth National Insurance number so when
you do it particularly if you're using
your friend's phone bring your National
Insurance number because not everybody's
got it in their head
and criminality declaration also at this
stage the home office once you've done
those two things the home office then
checks against your National Insurance
number the tax authority and the
benefits authority how long before they
told you the answer
so between Saturday and Monday you were
told you'd go and did they ask for any
additional information
yeah okay right
okay
so that's good so in your in in this
gentleman's case he did it on Saturday
he got confirmation that it was
successful on the Monday so that's very
quick but also they within that time
they checked his National Insurance
record it confirmed he'd being here the
period he said so they didn't need any
more information if you know your
national insurance record isn't going to
show that then you will have ready some
additional documents the hospital record
the school record the bank statements
whatever in theory you can photograph
those and you're supposed to be able to
upload them at the same time you use the
app but I can see from various comments
on websites that a lot of people having
trouble with that so if you don't
succeed or if the Home Office tells you
well that's fine but we do need a bit of
additional information for the year 2010
then you might end up having to post it
to the home office against your
reference number that you've just
received online but they still say
they're turning that around within two
weeks
yeah
well now
fees the fee is
you can't use that for no those of us
with Apple can't use it no the minister
the Home Secretary himself went in
person to Silicon Valley to talk to
Apple Apple are bigger than any country
is easy but they are talking to Apple so
you have to borrow one or use a facility
yeah yes you can you as not can we can
we go on with the presentation that
we'll have question and answer so write
down the questions that you have and
then we'll have that session because we
need to have an overview of the you
settlement state fees the fee
half that for children up to the age of
16 30 2015 you may remember that Teresa
may popped up a couple of weeks ago in
the House of Commons and said she
because she wasn't agreeing to anything
else she agreed this to do away with the
fees by that time the home office had
already put the system in place they
couldn't change it overnight so
currently you will still be asked when
you make the online application there's
a page to pay the fee 65-pound each 30
to 54 children up to 16 but it will be
refunded so anybody who has paid it or
is about to pay it will be refunded they
haven't explained yet how but given that
you're paying by online by credit or
debit card the normal way to repay is
back through the credit debit card but
they say that by the end of March when
the full scheme is open applications the
fee will have disappeared from the
application site
and also there are some people who don't
have to pay a fee if you already got
permanent residents and you paid the fee
for that sixty five quid you don't have
to pay again if you already got
indefinite leave but you don't have to
pay we have explained that from 21
January some EU citizens have been able
to test the application but they've had
to have the current valid passport it'll
be open to all by the 30th of March and
the deadline to submit applications will
be 30 June 21 but please bear in mind
the freedom of movement ei law only
applies up until the end of 2020
with more or less explained that for an
application to be valid it's got to meet
the home office rules currently
applications are being made in the UK
obviously there will be possibilities
for family members abroad to join family
here the fee was payable but it's now
scrapped although you still have to pay
it until they can repay proof event
identity and nationality and you've got
to provide a photo one of the other
helpful things that is quite unusual for
their home office and it's a reason why
it was a very high success rate so far
if you do something wrong if you fail to
give a piece of information and a piece
of evidence they're not supposed to just
say no you haven't done it right we're
refusing which is what they do with most
other applications they are supposed to
contact you and say excuse me wonder if
you could help us out can you provide a
bit more information or can you clarify
something so they give you another
chance and that so they're helping you
at the application they want you to
succeed and that must be happening
because actually be the only explanation
why nearly all of the applications to
date in the test phases have succeeded
and either even if you were refused you
can still make the application again and
give me look there's no fear if there's
a problem you just correct it the next
time you make
and we've discussed that the application
on your Android enabled device will
verify your passport EU citizens can
still use their national ID card but
they will have to post them to the home
office and if you have family members
who want to use citizens they will have
to send their bio map biometric
residence permits with the application
so in many cases there will be
supporting documents going by post
because
now the Home Office is providing Oh
also there may be some people refugees
for example who don't have passports you
can't get passports and in such
circumstances the Home Office will
accept reasonable alternatives we've
said that the tax and benefits computers
will inform the home of his computer of
evidence measured against the National
Insurance number and we have explained
that if the Home Office is satisfied
there's evidence of five years residents
you'll get settled status no time limit
which is the best if you've got evidence
at less than five years they will give
you a period of five years pre settled
status and once you've clocked up five
years you can apply for settled spaces
even if you're somebody who already has
permanent residents you still have to
apply to convert the permanent residents
to settled status
I've explained that continuous residence
means residents of at least six months
in any 12-month period it's alright to
have an occasional you can have a gap
for an important reason
for example serious illness and
compulsory military service doesn't
count as breaking your continuous
residence
if you're absent for more than six
months then you break your continuous
residence in terms of clocking up and
entitlements under the second status
scheme if you get a prison sentence you
also break your continuous residence
because being in a prison doesn't count
as being resident in the UK if you get a
deportation order exclusion order then
or even in some cases if you're removed
from the UK which is a different
procedure than deportation then you
break your continuous residence so when
you get out of prison or when you come
back the clock starts again so there are
those danger zones that could break your
residence there are some people who can
qualify for settled status with less
than five years if they've been living
and working here for certain periods of
time and they're now becoming pensioners
or they're permanently incapacitated and
can't work
there's some examples of when
EU law has been benign children if the
family if the parents are applying for
settle status because of five years
continuously residents even if the
children haven't clocked up five years
the children of the family will also get
settled status at the same time we've
explained that there's a criminality
check
we've also explained that if you are the
subjects of the deportation order which
is usually to do with it in a custodial
sentence and or even a removal decision
then you can also be deemed not suitable
for leave to remain in the UK and the
Home Office takes a dim view of some
other sorts of behavior which could
include not being completely honest with
the Home Office you remember I mentioned
that if you do have any criminal
offending even if it's very small always
mention it because if you don't use that
as deception and the Home Office will
think that you are not a suitable person
if you practice reception and they can
refuse you on the grounds of suitability
the Home Office encourages people to
make family applications together so
they consider them all together that
makes sense if you have a family member
who's not in EU citizen the Brazilian
wife or the Algerian husband we
mentioned before then in addition to
evidence of identity nationality and
residence you also have to provide
evidence of that relationship marriage
to bring the non EU family member under
the umbrella of protection so evidence
of the relationship if you've got non EU
I've explained that even if you already
got permanent residence
if you've got permanent residents you
are supposed to convert it to settle
status under the new scheme and the Home
Office will deal with it promptly even
if you've got indefinite leave granted
under the UK immigration rules which
means your status is secure
you've got the equivalent of settle
States as it's just called a different
name no time limit no restrictions there
may be a benefit in applying for settled
status because indefinite leave can be
lost after two years absence the Home
Office is tolerating five years absence
for Europeans getting settled status so
there's that one difference that one
additional benefit that EU citizen is
getting separate status a gap an absence
of five years will not break will not
lose the settled status once acquired so
that's better than indefinite leave
under which you could lose it after two
years but that may change
in the future
the deadline to submit applications is
30 June 2020 t1 but remember you have to
qualify as resident here by the end of
December 2020 if you miss a deadline
in the event of refusal you can always
ask for a review appeal rights are
complicated and are changing so the
better option is to make the application
sooner rather than later if there's a
problem with it cure the problem and
make another application evidence of
what you've got which we have talked
about there because it's all gonna be on
this online you won't get a letter from
the home office you won't get a nice
little card saying what your state or
stamp in the passport it's all going to
be online now ok crossing a frontier
immigration officers are going to be
able to access the Home Office website
to check your status they'll be able to
see that online but as you mentioned if
you're applying for a job or you're
applying for a tendency employers
landlords banks they all want to know
what your immigration status is these
days
for employers and for landlords the Home
Office has set up special lines lines of
inquiry obviously you would have to give
your permission or you can simply show
the landlord the employer your own
record to access a record of what you've
got you've got your separate status
you've got your preset status you would
have to go back into the home office
website you have to input your the
number on the document of identity that
you used your passport which is one of
the reasons why when you change your
passport you've got to tell the Home
Office because you might be inputting a
new you've got to put your date of birth
and then the home office will send you a
code you know credit cards have now
started sending codes if you do make
online payments you have to write it
down quick and then you input that to
get through to your records to show some
video status
yeah but the scheme for EU nationals
that opened on the 21st of January was
only taking passports when it opens for
everybody by the end of March you can
use a passport or an ID card but the
digital application that's downloaded
can only read near-field communication
those digital readable stuff so if your
ID card doesn't have that you'll have to
post it it will take long so you can
still use it it just takes a bit longer
yeah no no do not
if your family members or not themselves
in you nationals they'll be they will be
issued with a little card biometric
residence party we've said that if you
get pre settled status to be able to get
settled status you have to continue to
live in the UK and clock up five years
you can carry on traveling to and fro
using a valid passport or valid ID card
and the home office said at least for
another five years after the end of the
transition period which is December 2025
but be aware if you're in any doubt
about the need to apply for a passport
the home office is moving towards
passports are you away from ID cards as
well as moving to online applications
there are often questions about applying
for citizenship because whereas settled
status which is indefinite leave is the
most secure form of immigration status
because it has no time limit no
restrictions conditions the only way you
can avoid ever being deported no matter
what you do is if you become a British
citizen and of course this is a lot in
the news now in the context of people
who have joined Isis in the Middle East
and who want to come back if their
British citizens then they have every
right to come back to be able to
naturalize to become a british citizen
in general terms you have to have lived
here continuously for five years and you
have had you have to have had indefinite
leave residence settle status all the
same thing
for at least 12 months at least a year
which ever you've had if you've had it
for a year or if you get settle status
after you've had it for a year
but there of course there are other
rules for citizenship as well
right just a few words we've been
talking about the assumption that there
will be a deal agreed by the end of
March or possibly just after that if
there's an extension of time granted if
there's no deal by the end of March a
you free movement law will cease at the
end of March so the main difference will
be
the main difference will be the time
scale
the deal we've been talking about I told
you to treasure the date 31 December
2020 so long as you're resident by that
date you qualify for settles but under
the settlement scheme the qualifying
date if we fall out of you at the end of
March without a deal
see this is these poisonous crosses mean
No Deal
we fall out without a deal the
qualifying date is the 29th of March so
you have to be resident here at that
date to qualify you still have the
transition period you can apply up to
the end of December 2020 but there's no
little extra six months of tolerance no
extra six months of tolerance and you
have to make your application by then so
you still have time it's just shunted it
shunted it back a bit you're all here
tonight so you obviously will qualified
because your resident before March if
you've got an uncle in your in another
EU country and he's thinking about
coming here under this scheme so long as
he arrived by the end of December 2020
he could make his application under the
settlement scheme if we fall out without
a deal you'd better warn him that it's
sensible if he comes here before the end
of March if he wants to be sure that he
can apply under the settlement scheme
and otherwise the scheme is the saying
you apply for pre settlers or settle
status is just the time moves and it's
slightly less beneficial
well it's considerably less beneficial
what happens what happens after the
scheme the transition finishes and in a
No Deal scenario what happens if
somebody from an EU country arrives on
the 1st of April after the end of March
and we've left with No Deal
so there's they've got no further
protection what the Home Office has said
is that EU nationals with a passport or
an ID card can still come into the UK
and work but they will get three months
that's limited leave okay
automatically if they want to stay they
can apply remember I say you have to do
something from now on under UK
immigration rules and they have to apply
and they can get an extension of three
years and they can carry on working so
they can clock up three years three
months but they won't necessarily be
able to get settled stasis or
indefinitely because by then we'll be
well into UK immigration rules period
and UK immigration rules will probably
require certain skills levels certain
minimum salary so being an EU national
just won't cut it any more will not
suffice so if we leave with no deal any
EU national arriving after the end of
March we'll just get limited leave and
may not be able to settle here
permanently under the lightly agreed
scheme anybody arriving after the end of
December 2020
the same applies they won't be able to
get privileged status as EU nationals
they'll just get limited leave
thank you
and there are some sources of further
information on this slide also
I saw I can hold this one no no you
didn't have to hold this
how to get help
um because not everybody's got an
Android or no it has a friend with an
Android the Home Office has said that
paper applications might be available in
certain circumstances but they have to
say that to comply with equality
legislation and but they haven't
explained under what circumstances
otherwise a lot of people are going to
be able to make the online application
but they might still need to send their
identity card or documents about gaps in
residence to the home office in the post
if you or you know somebody who just
can't handle the online application
there are some places they can go to for
help some local authorities have agreed
to provide help people make an
appointment they bring in their passport
and the local authority will do the
scanning using a local for it using a
council Android device and send it to
the home office to take the photo
so it's limited to that some libraries
are going to be able to do the same
thing and I understand that they can
they the local authorities in the
libraries can charge 14 pounds for help
with scanning then there's a voluntary
body called migrant helpline they're
providing telephone advice paid for by
the Home Office similarly an
organization called
we are digital who I think already
helped a lot of local authorities to
digitize services they're providing
telephone and email advice and their
website says they can provide face to
face device advice for some people
um and of course the home office you can
well they say you can go to a home
office office but not too sure about
that the home of is also because all
applications are going digital are
setting up a network of application
centers with private contractors who
will be charging so what before you make
an appointment with anybody anywhere
find out what the charges might be right
any questions
so I'll come around okay
I would like to ask you if my passport
now everything will end I have we is
loosely for my
so yeah okay right so your passport is
still in your unmarried name okay yes
yes yes yes well well there's two issues
one is providing evidence of residence
now to prove you've been here albeit in
a married name you provide the marriage
certificate because that shows your
maiden name and that you were married so
that will still be good evidence of
residence
well they'll want to see a copy of the
marriage certificate yeah and if the
marriage what language is the marriage
certificate in sorry is it in more than
one language just one so you will also
have to provide a certified copy
translation by a professional translator
okay then as well as the original
Italian births marry certificate but in
terms of your record if you want to be
known on the home of which record in
your married name then you would because
they will only use the name that's on
your passport so you would have to get a
new passport
oh yes yeah yeah I think this is the
same in France as well I think yeah yeah
yes well yeah okay well just it well if
you explain that to the Home Office
they'll be aware that some I think I
think the passport usually says then it
says the name is that's right Marie do
so it does actually provide evidence of
the married name so that will be in the
passport in effect yeah no no no could I
remind people that this has been videoed
and will it be available from tomorrow
and also copies of the slides will be on
the website as well settle status yes
[Music]
okay no time limit that's what it means
no time limit
you still have to pay the fee that's
right the same fee is everybody applying
to naturalize and you that's right you
have to do a knowledge of language and
life test oh if you've got an English
language degree that's that qualifies as
evidence of sufficient English language
but you'd still have to do the knowledge
of life in the UK test so you've got the
English language bit with an English
language degree you still have to do
them and of course you remember that
even those in EU citizen you can have
long absences from the UK without losing
your settle status if you want to
naturalize you mustn't be out of the UK
more than four hundred and fifty days in
the previous five years
and not more than 90 days in the
preceding 12 months
oh you mean some local authorities and
some libraries oh yeah if you go via the
Home Office website or you can you can
put your local authority into to see if
they're providing that service on the
list of services but because the Home
Office's only recently started
encouraging local authorities to do this
the list keeps growing all the time so
if I looked at the list last week it's
probably a longer list this week as more
local authorities are providing this
service because the Home Office is
paying them a bit to do it Kennedy said
that at the moment have no idea whether
we provide that service we will find out
and we'll put it on the website but if
you know anybody with an android device
it's secure because the the Android
device of the other person doesn't
retain it it's not retained on the
Android device so it is safe to use
somebody else's Android device
[Music]
did you did you say evidence of income
no no no no not under the settle status
scheme and that's why that's one of the
reasons why it's good to apply under the
settle status scheme under your right
that under normal UK immigration rules
very often these applications engage a
minimum income of some sort but under
the settle status scheme they're just
looking for residence
no is the short answer to that but I'm
going to qualify up until now the norm
has been that if you got permanent
residence as an EU citizen then if you
have gone for two years or more you lost
there and that's in line with UK
immigration rules that if you got
indefinite leave to enter or remain
which is the same thing if you were out
of the country for two years you lost it
exceptionally under the settle status
scheme and this is one of the positive
factors the Home Office says that even
if you've been out of the country for
five years say you were here as an EU
national and you qualified as an EU
national working and living here in the
past then you went back to wherever
another country and you were gone for
five years
under current law that absence of more
than two years you'd have lost the
permanent residence you had previously
acquired the home office is now going to
overlook it as long as it's not more
than five years and you'd already
clocked up your five years to qualify
for permanent residence in the past they
will still give you settled status they
are also saying that from now on you can
have a five year absence as an EU
citizen and not lose your settle status
so once you apply now you get your
settled status you clear off for five
years they say you won't lose it but I
think you should keep your eye on that
in terms of going into the future
because the home office changes its mind
occasionally so I wouldn't advise
anybody to rely on that but that's what
they're saying at the moment did that
make sense is that okay that good
[Music]
[Music]
where is she
no but where is she now yes yes well
she's not here now under the the deal
scheme for settled status that is the
agreed scheme which involves a
transition period after the end of March
until the end of December 2020 there is
still freedom of movement so she could
still come to live with you in the UK
she can do that firstly because she's
herself an EU citizen and in addition
she's also a family member and you're
entitled to have your mother as a
qualifying family member but she is
herself an EU national so she can come
here up until the end of December 2020
she won't get a National Insurance
number in any way if she's not in the
country and you can't apply for her
under the settle status scheme until
she's in the country as things stand now
if we leave with no deal it will be much
more difficult to bring her unless you
bring her by the end of March because
the main qualify
factories to be resident by the end of
March but we're all hoping we won't end
up at the end of March with a No Deal
because it will cause so many problems
[Music]
yes doing it all evening so those yeah
so those are some difficulties to bring
her here yeah but I have to say that you
have to make a decision during this
transition period because after that
once you go into UK immigration rules
once you're out of the transition of
protection UK immigration rules make it
virtually impossible to bring an elderly
parent here just because of care needs
it's virtually impossible thank you for
the question
I'm very conscious of time so we've got
five minutes left when you were here as
a student did you have comprehensive
sickness insurance no so you probably
wouldn't have got one then anyway
although the home office isn't looking
for that now no it's just that the
National Insurance number is very good
evidence that's all but as long as you
can prove continuous residents since the
date you arrived without gaps of more
than well well well
it's a sin essentially they're looking
for a five year period to count it yes
yes yes yes they will be on the Stratfor
district council website
[Music]
yes yes yeah well that's right those
pensions are aggregated over your
working life and the coordinating body
it's part of the Maine DWP in Newcastle
long benton is it with a funny postcode
so it it's easy to find just by just put
DWP pensions into google and you'll come
up with it and they collect the
information from other countries you've
worked in Germany in your case so they
should be administering and know what
your accumulated pension is for the time
you've worked in the UK time you worked
in Germany and that's not supposed to
change
find well reciprocal arrangements
henceforth will be between the 27
countries individually yes well there
already are because there were some
reciprocal arrangements which proceeded
the community and similarly we have
reciprocal arrangements with non EU
countries too so it's quite a
complicated hotchpotch but the starting
point for all inquiries not least
because there are different arrangements
involving different reciprocal
agreements the starting point is that
there's an office that it has expertise
in those arrangements in Newcastle and
I'm going to be around for a while as
well tottering around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
currently you can drive on a different
driving license for a year
[Music]
again it's going to be reciprocal
arrangements that's right
yes
fine
can can we draw this session to a close
now please because normally at 8 o'clock
the office is closed so can I just say
in conclusion I think one of the quotes
of the night as being sometimes people
get confused and I have to say I think
it's being very informative but I think
there's still quite a lot of work to do
to sort out all the particular issues
nevertheless as I've said the webcast
will be available tomorrow and the
slides will be available tomorrow so
with that thank you all for coming and
over to you Manuela
[Music]
[Applause]